i'm delighted delighted to be talking
about this amazing series which
man the the chemistry with you and tom
and and riding the line of drama and
comedy is striking dude
it's really really cool to watch now
were you not
that familiar with the marvel universe
pre getting into this thing
no i wasn't that familiar and um
we've kind of talked about that tom was
very kind of
generous and kind of walking me through
all the
the kind of movies and specifically his
character
and that actually was we kind of called
it the loki school
and um with tom as the professor
and uh that was very helpful from
my character because i'm supposed to be
kind of an expert on loki
do you get extra brownie points as a dad
for being part of a show like this or or
is it just like do the kids
overlook this type of stuff i think that
it's going to be
yeah definitely going to get your street
cred is gonna come up when you're
a part of the marvel universe you're
working with the god of
mischief right what kind of stuff are
you gonna get roped into that you didn't
want to be a part of
well of course when you're with the god
of mischief
uh you got to be ready for uh the
unexpected
and i think that loki you know kind of
he definitely keeps my character on his
toes but having sort of been
um you know studied him
and uh prepared for this meeting
uh i'm i'm pretty adept at being ready
for
his kind of tricks but uh of course you
can't always
prepare for everything that loki's gonna
throw at you are you taking me somewhere
to kill me
no that's where you just were i'm taking
you someplace to talk
but i don't like to talk but you do like
to lie which you just did
because we both know you love to talk
i imagine you're having a blast uh
playing along
a long time are you not yeah we really
um
i think it was you know you never know
how you're gonna sort of
get along working with somebody and i
think it was really
um you know the whole cast but
um so much of my stuff was with loki
and i it was just um i think we did good
stuff
do we have a chance of seeing some of
the other wonderful characters from the
universe pop up
uh can you give us anything a little bit
of a tease throughout the season of loki
there's always a chance uh that
something could pop
up but um i think that one of the nice
things about
um you know people are kind of very
familiar with this loki character is
that there's going to be some kind of
new
uh aspects to loki and seeing some
kind of new colors that he's playing
that
i think that people are going to be
excited to see
let's switch gears a little bit i want
to talk the royal tenon bombs dude the
20th
anniversary that's kind of like hard to
to wrap your head around
well everyone knows custer died a little
bighorn what this book presupposes is
maybe he didn't i think we're gonna do
some sort of
anniversary um zoom thing
what i remember was being in new york
and uh of course gene hackman is royal
but just kind of a great cast in that
movie
and working with ben stiller again
and my brother it turned out very well
talk to me the other uh upcoming film
viewers everybody's excited about marry
me with the uber talented j-lo
you guys together seems like a damn
no-brainer to me it seems perfect what
was that like for you
her character was great kind of because
she's doing a lot of
singing and uh we really had a good cast
maluma
and uh a lot of good people in it we had
worked together on anaconda so
uh it was nice to uh to sort of
meet up with jen after all these years
and work on marrying me
and um i think that that movie turned
out pretty well